-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Rob McElhenney
"Always Sunny"
renewed to Season 18.
As you mentioned,
"Mythic Quest" --
100% on Rotten Tomatoes.
You just bought
a football team in England
I want to talk
to you about that.
But the biggest heat you hav
right now --
-Seth, I bought a football tea
in North Wales.
-North Wales.
-Yes.
-Yes, thank you very much
for clarifying.
Yes, I should have said Britain.
I apologize.
But this is your heat right no
is you found a dog.
I should say your wife and
co-star, Kaitlin, found a dog.
-Yes. So, I've got a couple of
TV shows on the air right now,
and we just announced anothe
one yesterday.
And all anybody
wants to ask me about
on Instagram or Twitter
is about this dog.
-It's a pretty good-looking dog.
-It's a great-looking dog.
Kaitlin found this dog on
the freeway here in L.A.
And she miraculously --
and with a person that she met
on the freeway -- saved this dog
and eventually got
the dog into the car.
And she brought him home,
and we fell in love with him
I mean, his paws
were all ripped up,
because, clearly, he had bee
running for 40 or 50 miles
they suggested, because
his paws were all torn apart
And so we had him
all stitched up.
And we were all ready to mak
him a member of our family
We named him.
We even had a name for him
because he has a giant hea
and tiny, little legs,
so we called him Frank Reynolds.
-Okay. That makes sense.
For fans -- This is
a very good Frank Reynolds
photo right there.
There you go, yeah.
-Well, That's a very -- that's a
very DeVito pose, isn't it
-It really is, yeah, 'cause he
tends to be shot down on.
-Yeah, yeah. Well, sure.
There's no other
direction to go.
So, we were psyched.
We had a dog.
And I Instagrammed about it in
a story, and we were pumped.
I mean, we already have
two other dogs.
And, so, my kids fell in lov
with Frank Reynolds.
And then I got a text, a
mysterious text from somebody,
who said,
"I know the owner of that dog.
And I said, "Who is this?"
And she said -- Well, the person
said, "I am a pet detective.
So now I knew -- Like, I kne
someone was trolling me,
because -- And I didn't know
who this number --
where this number came
from or who it was.
But I went along
with the bit and I responded
and it turned out that,
no, this person
had scoured the Internet
and found photos of a reward
that was given --
of a reward page
that was plastered all ove
this one neighborhood
in Los Angeles
and wasn't even online.
Somehow, she figured it out,
found it out,
found my information,
found my phone number,
my home address,
and tracked us down
and reunited the dog, who's --
Apparently, the dog's name
was not Frank Reynolds.
The dog's name was Chance.
But she tracked us down,
and I was, like, blown away.
This was all over
the course of 20 minutes.
They said -- 20 minutes
from the time I posted it.
I said, "How did you find me?"
And she said,
"Rob, I'm a pet detective.
I can find anybody."
And I was like, "Oh."
Click.
I mean, I thought she was
in the Mossad or something
So, anyway, I did a deep cleanse
of my information
on the Internet.
But my guess is, if she want
to, she'll find me again.
-This sounds like -- There's a
sad element that you lost Frank,
but we should point out
that, you know,
this was a happy ending,
that Chance --
We actually --
There's a video of Chance
seeing his family again,
which was very nice.
-Yes.
-Hi, baby!
-Chance!
-I mean,
look how happy that dog is
-I don't know. I'm not sure.
I think it's a scam.
I think that's not --
-That is a happy dog.
And, of course, we were bummed
that we missed out on
Frank Reynolds,
but we were so happy
that he was returned.
-We alluded to it.
So, this is
a pretty awesome story.
Wrexham -- am I saying it right?
That's the name of the Welsh
club that you have purchased
-Yes. That's right.
-So, you and Ryan Reynolds
bought a very
low-division, a sort of
underperforming-but-historic
football club.
How did this come about?
This was your idea?
-Yes. Yeah.
Just over the pandemic,
I really got into football
I have to call it football now
because if I call it soccer,
I'm gonna get stabbed
when I go to North Wales.
So I just make sure --
I don't code switch.
I don't come back to America
and then start saying "soccer,
because I'll get --
I really will.
If I slip up, there will b
a beating involved.
-Yeah, I think that's safe
That's smart.
-Yeah. So it's
very clearly "football."
And I just started
getting into watching football
and watching
football documentaries.
And I was not
a big fan of it in the past,
you know, because it's not
a huge sport here in America
But I got into it big-time
And once I learned about
how you could be
promoted and relegated
out of the league,
that really piqued my interest
because that's just so not
a part of American sports.
I mean, if so, you know,
there would be teams
you know, at the bottom of
the NFL every year
that would be booted down to
playing out of the --
They would no longer be
a part of the league.
So, I thought,
"Well, if you can get relegated,
you can also get promoted.
So if you go far down enough
and you can find a club
that maybe I could afford,
that maybe I could help
that club to be promoted u
into higher leagues.
So that's what I did.
-Has the fan base embraced
the idea of you and Ryan so far?
-They have thus far, yes.
I mean, we've been
very respectful and very careful
about how
we're approaching this.
We recognize that we're
an American and a Canadian
We're also Hollywood types
And I don't know
if you've noticed this, Seth
but a lot of people
don't trust Hollywood types.
I don't know why.
-That's true.
I have noticed that.
-I don't know why.
I don't know what agenda
they believe we have.
Maybe certain agendas that are
espoused on your program.
I don't know.
-Well, it should be noted
that you mentioned
a third TV show.
You're going to do a documentary
about owning this club.
-Yeah, so,
that was a key part of this.
So, I got really invested in
a bunch of documentaries
that I was watching
over the pandemic,
which I know a lot of
people were, as well.
I got really into
"Chef's Table,"
"Last Chance U,"
and I got really into "Cheer."
And it turns out that
there's one company
that makes
all of those documentaries
And I reached out to them
and I said, "I love your shows
I'm going through
this weird process.
Would you consider
documenting this?"
And they said yes.
This company
is called Boardwalk.
And they're going to
document the entire process.
-It's really exciting.
I can't wait to see it.
And congrats on everything
It's really nice to
talk to you, buddy.
-Thank you. You too, Seth.
Good to see you.
-I will see you soon.
"Mythic Quest" is streamin
now on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."